para que puedas vivir tu vida,
y no la historia que te has contado
sobre tu vida.
Y así es como sorteamos esas rejas.
Así que quiero volver a la carta de esa mujer, la de la infidelidad.
Me preguntó que debería hacer.
Tengo esta palabra anotada en mi oficina:
"ultracrepidarianismo".
La costumbre de dar consejos u opiniones que exceden nuestro saber y competencias.
Gran palabra, ¿verdad?
Se puede usar en cualquier contexto,
Estoy segura de que la usarán tras esta charla TED,
La uso porque me recuerda que, como sicoterapeuta,
puedo ayudar a la gente a planear lo que quiere hacer,
pero no puedo hacer sus elecciones vitales por ellos.
Solo Uds. pueden escribir su propia historia
y solo necesitan algunas herramientas.
Así que, lo que quiero hacer
es editar la carta de esta mujer, todos juntos, aquí y ahora,
para poder mostrarles cómo revisar nuestras historias.
Y quiero empezar pidiéndoles
que piensen en una historia que se estén contando a Uds. ahora
que quizás no les esté ayudando.
Puede ser sobre una circunstancia que estén experimentando,
sobre una persona de su vida,
incluso sobre Uds. mismos.
Y quiero que se fijen en los actores de reparto.
¿Qué personas les están ayudando
a sostener la versión errada de esta historia?
Por ejemplo, si la mujer que me escribió esta carta
contara a sus amigos lo que pasaba,
seguramente le ofrecerían lo que se llama "compasión idiota".
En la compasión idiota -siguiendo con esta historia-
diríamos: "Tienes razón, es horrible",
cuando un amigo nos dice que no le dieron el ascenso que quería,
aun cuando sabemos que ya le pasó varias veces
porque realmente no se esforzó,
y es probable que robara el material de oficina.
(Risas)
Decimos: "Tienes toda la razón, ese es un imbécil".
Cuando una amiga nos dice que su novio la dejó,
aun cuando sabemos que hay algunas cosas
que hace normalmente con sus novios,
como atiborrarlos de mensajes o rebuscar en sus cajones,
que traen esas consecuencias.
Vemos el problema,
es como si cada vez que vas al bar hay siempre una pelea,
quizás seas tú.
(Risas)
Para ser buenos editores, hay que ofrecer compasión sabia,
no solo a nuestras amistades, sino a nosotros mismos.
Esto se llama -creo que el término técnico sería-
"Bombardeo compasivo de verdades".
Y esas bombas de verdades son compasivas
porque nos ayudan a ver lo que hemos obviado en nuestra historia.
Lo cierto es que no sabemos si el marido está teniendo una aventura,
o por qué su vida sexual cambió hace dos años,
o qué son esas llamadas telefónicas que hace de madrugada.
Y eso podría ser la razón de su historia,
Ella habla de una historia de traición,
pero es probable que haya algo más
que no me dice en su carta,
o quizás ella misma no lo ve.
Es como ese tipo que hace el test de Rorschach.
¿Saben como son los test de Rorschach?
Un sicólogo te enseña unas manchas de tinta parecidas a esto,
y pregunta: "¿Qué ve Ud. aquí?"
Entonces el tipo mira la mancha y dice:
"Bueno, definitivamente, no veo sangre".
Y el examinador dice:
"Muy bien, dígame qué más no ve, definitavamente".
En literatura, esto se llama "punto de vista".
¿Qué no quiere ver el narrador?
Quiero leerles otra carta.
Dice así:
"Querida terapeuta,
necesito que me ayude con mi mujer.
Últimamente se enfada por todo,
incluso por minucias, como el ruido que hago cuando mastico.
En el desayuno he visto que le está echando más leche a mi granola
para que no cruja tanto".
(Risas)
"Siento que es muy crítica conmigo desde que murió mi padre hace dos años.
Él y yo estábamos muy unidos
y su padre los dejó cuando era joven,
así que no pudo entender por lo que pasaba.
Tengo una amiga en el trabajo cuyo padre murió hace unos meses
y que entiende mi pena.
Me gustaría poder habla con mi esposa como hablo con mi amiga,
pero creo que ya no me soporta.
¿Cómo puedo recuperar a mi mujer?".
Muy bien.
Supongo que ya han descubierto
que es la misma historia que les he leído antes,
justo desde el punto de vista de otro narrador.
La historia de ella iba de un marido que la engañaba,
la de él va de una esposa que no entiende su pena.
Pero lo que llama la atención es que,
con todas las diferencias que existen entre ambas historias,
hay un deseo de acercarse.
Y si pudiésemos ignorar al narrador en primera persona
y escribir la historia desde la perspectiva de otro personaje,
de repente este último se vuelve más empático
y el argumento se abre.
Este es el paso más duro en el proceso de editar
pero también es de donde arranca el cambio.
¿Qué pasaría si vieses tu historia
y la escribieras desde el punto de vista de otro?
¿Qué verías entonces desde una perspectiva más amplia?
Por eso, cuando veo gente deprimida, a veces digo:
"Justo ahora no eres la mejor persona con quien hablar de ti",
ya que la depresión distorsiona nuestras historias especialmente.
Reduce nuestra perspectiva.
Sucede lo mismo cuando nos sentimos solos, heridos o rechazados.
Creamos toda clase de historias,
distorsionadas por una lente diminuta
que nos impide saber qué estamos viendo.
Y es cuando nos hacemos reemisores de nuestras propias noticias falsas.
Debo confesarles algo.
Yo escribí la versión del marido de la carta que les leí.
No se imaginan cuánto tiempo invertí
debatiendo entre granola y tostaditas, por cierto.
La escribí basándome en todos los narradores alternativos
que he visto en estos años,
no solo como sicoterapeuta, sino también en mi columna.
Cuando me ha pasado
que dos personas viviendo la misma situación
me han escrito, sin saber el uno del otro,
y tengo dos versiones de la misma historia
en mi bandeja de entrada.
Me ha pasado de verdad.
No sé cuál es la otra versión de la carta de esta mujer,
pero sí sé esto:
Ella tenía que escribirla.
Porque con una edición valiente,
ella escribirá una versión más aproximada de la que me escribió a mi.
Incluso si su marido la está engañando
-y quizás lo esté haciendo-
ella no necesita saber de qué va el argumento.
Porque solo por haberlo editado,
ella tendrá más posibilidades de que el argumento cambie.
Pero a veces sucede que veo gente atrapada de verdad,
metida de verdad en su estancamiento.
Se llaman "quejicas que rechazan ayuda".
Seguro que conocen a gente así.
Son los que, cuando les haces una sugerencia,
la rechazan con un "bueno, no, eso no funcionará porque..."
"Bueno, no, imposible, no puedo hacerlo".
"Sí, quiero tener más amigos, pero la gente es insoportable".
(Risas)
Lo que realmente rechazan
es la edición de su historia de miseria y estancamiento.
Así que a estas personas me acerco de forma diferente.
Y lo que hago es decirles algo más.
Les digo:
"Todos vamos a morir".
Apuesto a que Uds. están contentos de no tenerme de sicóloga.
Porque ellos me miran
como Uds. me están mirando ahora
absolutamente aturdidos.
Pero entonces les explico que hay una historia
que al final se escribe sobre todos nosotros.
Se llama obituario.
Y digo que en lugar de escribir nuestra propia infelicidad,
debemos moldear esas historias mientras todavía vivimos.
Tenemos que ser el héroe y no la víctima en nuestra historia,
debemos elegir qué sucede en la página que vive en nuestra mente
y forma nuestras realidades.
Les digo que la vida se trata de decidir qué historias hay que escuchar
y cuáles necesitan una edición.
Y que vale la pena esforzarse por pasar por una revisión
porque no hay nada más importante para la calidad de vida
que las historias que nos contamos acerca de ellas.
Les digo que cuando algo influye en la historia de nuestra vida,
deberíamos optar a nuestro propio Premio Pulitzer personal.
Pero la mayoría no somos quejicas que rechazan ayuda
o, al menos, creemos que no lo somos.
Pero es un rol en el que es muy fácil caer
cuando estamos tensos, enfadados o indefensos.
Así que la próxima vez que algo les agobie,
recuerden:
todos vamos a morir.
(Risas)
Echen mano a sus herramientas de edición
y pregúntense:
"¿Cómo quiero que sea mi historia?
Y luego, escriban su obra maestra.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)